what a profound pleasure it is to be
back here this is I think the first time
I have been I in new haven for
professional reasons in 23 years and if
I my memory is correct the last time was
for the final consultation with my
dissertation advisors and I after that I
drove back to Washington with the only
copy of my thesis in the trunk of a car
stopped for dinner in Manhattan and when
I emerged from dinner discovered that
the trunk of the car had been rifled
with a crowbar and a small bag was
missing that contained some old clothes
a book or two and the only copy of my
dissertation so I got on the phone to to
Sid winter and I said said I want you to
be on the alert there is a distinct
possibility that someone else will try
to get a PhD awarded from Yale
University on the same topic that I've
been working on don't give it to him at
any rate it really is a profound
pleasure to be here and especially to
have the opportunity to talk about some
work that i have been doing with a small
and evolving group of graduate students
research students in the ph.d program
and public policy at the LBJ School of
Public Affairs University of Texas at
Austin where I have now been for about
19 years and this is work which passes
under the rubric of something we call
the University of Texas inequality
project most of it is available on the
website of our
small group and in particular I want to
talk today about a body of work related
to the measure of economic inequality of
several different kinds at the global
scale and this is based in part on a
paper that a recent PhD graduate and I
handsome combe have written which will
appear in the January issue of the
review of income and wealth larger
question to which we are in part
addressing ourselves has been rather
thoroughly described in an intensely
debated literature in recent months and
it is whether inequality in the world in
the age of globalization has been rising
or falling and it is now of course very
well understood that there are basically
three ways to approach this question one
of them here I'm borrowing from the work
of a former World Bank economist Bronco
milunovich one of these ways is to
simply use a measure of income
inequality between countries are not
waiting for population size and when you
do that using as your data source let's
say the pin world tables everybody
agrees that inequality has in fact been
rising but that agreement becomes
considerably muddied or indeed
contradicted if you wait by population
size because of the effects principally
of China and also to some extent of
India which have been growing very
rapidly therefore rising in
a relative income distribution and are
in a weighted measure reducing the
inequality of incomes across countries
neither of those questions of course
gets to the the deeper issue of what has
been going on inside national boundaries
which milana vez would call the true
within country and equality measure and
that remains rather hotly disputed to
see a summary of the Economist in recent
articles actually on two occasions has
picked up a little bit of an analysis
that appeared in Stanley Fisher's Eli
lecture in 2003 showing what happens if
you shift from an unweighted to a
weighted distribution this has got GDP
per head on the horizontal axis and the
growth from it 1982 2000 on the vertical
axis and so you can see the implication
of the top diagram is that the richer
countries have been growing faster and
therefore you've had divergence and an
increase in inequality and you can see
how that conclusion would be to some
extent reverse if you wait by population
because if you take out the countries in
sub-saharan Africa which have had a
particularly bad experience on the other
hand if you look at measures of true
inequality attempting to take account of
what's going on inside countries you
find what well there are a number of
studies that have attempted to get a
grip on this question they have in
almost all cases been only two able to
do so for a handful of years sometimes
two up to as many as four this one is a
lot of it
three and there's one exception which is
claimed to produce an inequality measure
within countries overall on an annual
basis and that is xavi a salary martin's
paper which claims to find that
inequality has been steadily declining
that paper is based upon a World Bank a
data set authored by two staff members
at the World Bank klaus-dieter and then
Squire which has become a standard
reference a bibliographic compilation of
measures of household income inequality
with strictly of household income
inequality measures of inequality in the
world economy and that's the source
material for Sally Martin well the
problem that we have is that upon
examining the core data set which has
been in use for presenting measures of
inequality within countries we find that
important questions have to be raised
and I want to first of all pose a couple
of questions that should be asked it
seems to me about data sets when you
don't know anything in particular about
how good they are in advance first
question you would want to know is how
much of the territory is covered and how
consistently in other words how much of
the world over how many years and
secondly it might be nice to know
whether the numbers can reasonably be
expected to be first of all accurate and
secondly comparable to each other and
I'm going to raise some questions about
the the Dinah juror and Squire data set
that will I hope persuade you that it's
at least worth while to look further
and see if there isn't off there aren't
alternative sources of information if
you look at the coverage and it would be
a good idea if someone could turn out
the lights in the room just to make it a
little bit more visible to the people in
the back is that possible yeah if you
look at the coverage I've displayed the
coverage of the what dine injure and
Squire called the high-quality subset of
their data set on a map showing the
number of observations where an
observation is a year for a country
available for the entire period for
which they have information from 1950
through the late 1990s and once you can
see is that while there are a few
countries for which information is
available on an almost annual basis that
tends to be more true of several rich
countries the United States Britain
Taiwan Japan India is not in such bad
shape but for most of the world you have
many fewer observations than that and
for most of the developing world you
have fewer than 10 observations over
almost a half centuries time and in many
cases it's actually considerably worse
than that you're relying on one or two
or three observations for many countries
including almost all of Africa it's also
data which has curious problems of
inconsistency across space and I've
tried to illustrate that on this map in
a very simple way by simply averaging
across time ignoring whatever patterns
there may be in the historical trends
just to get you an idea of the kinds of
measurement patterns that they present
over the world economy over this period
and two things that emerged very clearly
are the relative heterogeneity of the
European case and the relative
homogenate II of the Asian case what
I've done here is to take the to call
the low lowest third red and are
the middle group yellow and green and
the highest group light blue and dark
blue so you can get a sense of it of the
patterns in the data but here it is
slightly blown up for Europe and what
you can see is that for example France
and Italy are shown in this data as
having inequality measures which are
dramatically higher than those of the
immediately surrounding countries
something which seems to me to be a
little bit difficult to credit on a
priori grounds that is to say if it were
true since we know that France and
Germany have average incomes which are
very similar if it were true that the
variances were as different you might
expect to find low wage French workers
migrating to Germany in order to do
low-wage work because they would be a
gain in that but if you it's a test you
can do yourself if you go out on the
streets of Hamburg at five o'clock in
the morning and listen to the street
sweepers it seems to me very improbable
that they will be speaking French so
that seems to meet at least raise
questions about whether data collected
in this particular way which is
essentially a bibliographic compilation
of a range of studies done by official
and semi official groups at the national
level has in fact gotten you an
international data set which is a
reliable comparative study and on the
Asian side you have the opposite problem
in that the diner in quartz choir data
set tends to show low inequality
measures for not only China but also
such countries as India and Indonesia
lower in fact and for Japan and
Australia and that also given the
enormous disparity in differences in the
national economic systems seems to me to
be at least eyebrow-raising when I
raised this question at the World Bank
was that this was accounted for by the
highly agrarian character of the
particularly the Indonesian economy and
the relative equality of the agrarians
society but that only raises the
why in the case of Africa which is even
more agrarian do dyna turn squires
measures show a much higher inequality
estimates for most countries of
sub-saharan Africa for which they have
data so the whole thing seems to be at
least questionable it is well known that
in the Asian region you're mainly
relying on expenditure rather than
income surveys so this is not in fact
quite comparable data but the question
of what adjustment when should make
still then has to be addressed if one
looks again at the at the diner and
square data set one problem which has
been extensively pointed out in the
literature is in fact the heterogeneity
of the data sources on which they are
obliged to rely simply because of the
basic unavailability of consistent
alternatives so while a large part of
their measures are gross household
income they are also relying on net
expenditure on net income sometimes on
person per person gross income sometimes
on per person net income and so you have
a essentially a melange one might even
say a dog's breakfast of different kinds
of statistics and raising again an
important question about what
adjustments if anyone should make to to
put them on a comparable basis it's a
problem which is not only true within
country between countries but also
within within them this is the diners
and Squire measures for Spain showing a
sharp drop in inequality between the
early night men and the late 1970s which
is the time when Franco died and Spain
became democratic so one might expect
some such effect but on the other hand
there's also a shift from a household
gross income to a household net
expenditure survey and it's extremely
possible that at least part of the
decline in measured inequality in Spain
is simply a
a reflection of the different kinds of
data that are being collected in the
1980s and it's very hard to know I
priore again what to do about that if
one takes the World Bank's data set for
the OECD countries about which one has I
think very reasonable prior expectations
about what to believe and here we've
mapped it out across basically from left
to right is from the low inequality
countries to the high inequality
countries in their data and again I
think you can see some things which
ought to strike you is somewhat puzzling
in particular the fact that Sweden
Norway and Denmark the Scandinavian
countries appear in the middle of their
distribution for Europe with Spain in
the lower range something which it seems
to me flunks the airport test which is
to say fly to the country drive in to
the capital city from the airport and
see how much inequality you observe the
particularly good in the developing
world but it does seem to me that a
reasonable expectation for Europe would
be that credible data should show the
Scandinavian countries with relatively
low inequality measures and that just
doesn't happen to be true of the data
set that Dinah jerence choir in the
World Bank have been describing as a
high quality data set so that's where we
come in we're the University of Texas
inequality project and we are dedicated
to finding extremely inexpensive but we
hope reliable ways of adding to the
stock of information about inequality on
the global scale we have been first of
all involved in coming up with measures
of pay inequality at the global scale
using data sets that we acquired from
the United Nations basically the united
nations industrial statistics so for a
large part of our work we have been
restricting ourselves to the very small
part of the
economy that is represented by
manufacturing pay inequality we've been
applying very simple techniques that
have the advantage they're only
advantage that they do permit us to
measure things on an up-to-date basis at
extremely low cost as I said a minute
ago we use international data sets for
global comparisons especially you need
OHS industrial statistics but we go
beyond that as well as time and
resources have permitted we've been
adding to it regional and national data
sets including Europe Sri geo data set
regions we've been using national data
sets from Gotham stat in Russia from the
China state statistical agency from the
annual survey of industries in the
United in India and from a large number
of data sources including the local area
of personal income statistics of the
United States and we have published
papers on almost all of those topics and
some of which I've make available to the
center and leave for you here but today
I'm going to largely restrict myself to
the international comparison and its
derivatives which are based as I say
initially on you need ohs industrial
sadistics our method is to use the
between groups component of tiles p
statistic which is a very easy thing to
compute and which is facilitated in
international comparisons by the
existence of standardized categories
that is to say standardized industrial
classification schemes which you need oh
and also yours that provide and with
those classification schemes we are able
to compute a cross industries measure of
inequality from the unito industrial
statistics with over 3,200 cross country
observations this is the mathematics of
it and what we are basically using is
that between groups component of tiles
t-statistic tiles t-statistic has a very
lovely property of being dis agrega
belen to
in groups and within groups if you have
and since we do not have information on
what's going on within our groups within
our industrial sectors for example we're
basically restricting ourselves to the
between groups measure which turns out
however to be a very robust estimator of
the change in the shape of the whole
distribution over time if you're
sampling on a consistent basis and to
our surprise we also discovered and I'll
try to persuade you of this that it is a
pretty good estimator of comparative
inequality across countries so long as
things are measured on the same basis
move on mathematics will bother you with
but i'll turn you turn first to the
question of how much information you can
get on this admittedly very limited
economic quantity that is to say
inequality of pay in the manufacturing
sector and the answer is if you're
willing to narrow your focus you can
greatly expand your range and for the
period 1963 to 1999 we have a great many
countries for which we have essentially
annual observations so we're able to
construct dense and consistent time
series and only a few countries in areas
where manufacturing sectors are very
weak to non-existent for which data is
not available at all if you look then at
the next question is okay so you've got
this measure is it any good why should
anybody pay attention to it I'm going to
approach that through a series of
illustrations the first one is to take
two countries the US and the UK for
which we know the income inequality data
are dense and reasonably good and they
are on the left hand
side on the right-hand side you have our
measures and what you can see is that
while they are not identical they are
really quite similar in terms of their
patterns so what's going on in
industrial pay in the US and the UK is
broadly reflective of what's going on in
an overall measure of income inequality
that's not what's on the air vertical
axis in on the left hand side it would
be okay let me see here it's a sorry the
two series in comparison looking at the
movement of our inequality measure over
time for a number of places one of the
things that we find is that they do tend
to correspond it sometimes in quite
dramatic ways to known historical events
so for example we take our measures for
China and Hong Kong and you can see a
turning point which is very clear at
1989 which happens to be the moment of
the 10 at the June fourth incident in 10
MN square and a subsequent of slowdown
in the Chinese economy if you look at
Iran and Iraq rather topical choices and
I've always liked this graph because
they don't think the CIA has it you can
see that inequality in Iraq actually
declined in the 1970s the same was not
true of Iran until nineteen seventy nine
when the Iranian numbers came down very
sharply because the middle class was
executed and I mean the upper class was
executing and then of course during the
war both countries were mobilized the
inequality numbers stayed quite
compressed until the end of the war when
they go up again looking at inequality
in the southern cone of Latin America we
find that there is a turning point in
Chile which is rather starkly located in
1973 there's one in Argentina in 1976
obviously both
dates of military coup d'etat the two
countries diverge Chile is blue in
Argentina's green in this thing the
moment of the Philip Falklands War in
1982 which was also the moment of a
severe banking crisis in Chile if you
look again in north america actually
inequality in the united states go
starts rising in the early 1970s for
this data we have much more detailed
data for mexico we see a substantial
bump so this is by no means the best
estimate but we see by a substantial
bump in 1986 at the moment of the
dilemma madrid crisis in the interim to
the gap if you look at some places in
the world again in scandinavia actually
there's very little change in the data
so it's not true that inequality has
been rising everywhere in denmark it's
actually been falling according to these
measures however a little bit to the
south and east and central europe you
can see a pattern of stability until the
collapse of the communist regimes in
1989 and then an enormous increase in
every country for which we have
continuous measurement if you do the
same exercise that I described earlier
across space you find actually the
opposite pattern from what you see in
the World Bank data looking at Europe we
actually find the European measures to
be very consistent with each other the
broad sort of global scale discrepancies
no longer exist the Russian data riposte
1991 they would be very different if you
included the Soviet period but otherwise
it's nineteen sixty three to nineteen
ninety nine Eastern Northern Europe low
with some gradient toward increasing
inequality as you go toward the south in
Asia on the other hand we find a very
high level of heterogeneity a great deal
of disparity with China and Australia
coming in as low inequality countries
but India and Indonesia coming in as
high inequality countries in this
measure and we think at least that it's
reasonable to expect an area which is
genomically highly integrated to have
similar inequality measures
whereas an area which is highly dis
integrated not integrated could be
expected to explain origin at ease that
we find that that's a more if you like
plausible arrangement than the reverse
one I also want to show you something
which can't be done at all with the
dinosaur and Squire data but with the
very large number of observations that
we have we can also track the changes in
our data across countries and through
time and I can do this with a scale on a
series of maps that run from brown red
to brown for the largest decreases in
inequality light to dark blue for the
very largest increases if you just look
at the map for the 1960s for which we
don't have a whole lot of data you can
see that it's it's quite a diverse
picture actually quite a few regions of
the world where inequality is decreasing
a few others where it's increasing no
terribly interpretable but as the data
set becomes more dense and times move
move on you can begin to see some things
that are quite distinctive in the 1970s
at the moment of the oil boom we have a
consistent pattern of declining
inequality in the producing countries
and rising inequality in most of the
consuming countries which are going of
course through oil induced receptions at
this period as we move into the late
1970s and the 1980s the pattern changes
mostly toward very strong increases in
inequality concentrated initially in
Latin America with a significant
exception in China and India which are
not affected by the global debt crisis
and the global recession which is
hitting all the rest of the developing
world at this time and as you move along
into the 1990s you find the pattern of
rising inequality becomes most intense
in the area of the former Soviet Union
its neighbors and China with again a
significant exception which is in
Southeast Asia at a moment of it
boom driven by foreign direct investment
so in what I call the age of
globalization you have a distinct
pattern of rising inequality in most of
the world but again with with with a
regional exception now a couple of broad
generalizations first of them has to do
with what light our data might be able
to shine on the ancient and venerable
kuznetsov honest of a relationship
between the level of income and the
level of inequality in the development
process Kuznets of course argued that in
the process of a transition to an
industrial society inequality would tend
first to rise and then as
industrialization deepened and as you
move toward the institutions of the
welfare state but also as low-wage
agriculture became a smaller and smaller
part of the total workforce in equality
would then begin to decline this is a
touchstone for almost every paper that's
written on the inequality issue and most
of the recent work which has been based
upon the diner and squire work has a
thoroughly rejected the Kuznets
hypothesis has taken it as mistaken in
its application to the modern world and
as a result most of the current
literature has moved off into a
consideration which I consider to be
quite improbable on the face of
relationships between the initial state
of inequality and subsequent rates of
growth with some economists arguing that
low inequality is good for later growth
and other economist arguing that high
inequality is good for later growth and
with theoretical models being cooked up
to justify one position or another we
what we believe though is that that
recent trend of the literature is
essentially inconsistent with a finding
of a stable relationship between the
level of income and
level of inequality and therefore
depends upon the trustworthiness of the
conclusion that the original Kuznets
hypothesis no longer has a foundation in
fact but when you look at data which are
restricted again to pay which was after
all what simon kuznets was principally
interested in and he explicitly ruled
out adding in transfers and other forms
of income what we find is that in our
data there is a very consistent
continuing downward sloping relationship
between income and inequality countries
which are wealthier this is a regression
plane countries which are wealthier
which points to a second interesting
fact from this very simple linear
regression and that is that the plane
has been tilted upwards over the past 35
or 36 years that is to say there has
been a tendency for this downward
sloping Kuznets relationship to be
shifting out over time now that's not
the best way to look at this analysis
particularly given the fact that we have
a data set now with 3200 observations
from which we can construct a panel and
to which we can apply a panel data
analysis with fixed effects covering
both countries and time and controlling
for GDP per capita and when you do that
and look at the time effects what you
find is I think very interesting these
are the time effects from as I say a
two-way fixed effects model showing in
other words that part of the movement of
inequality in our data which is
consistent across
which is in a sense the global movement
of between of within countries
inequality essentially stable from 1963
through the end of the decade then a
period when there was a pattern of
decline that is say of falling
inequality in the world economy and then
an enormous turnaround in 1970 19 80 81
82 with 20 years of steady increases
afterwards and when I look at that data
and apply what I believe I know about
the history of the world economy to it I
say I think I am observing here a the if
you like the cloud chamber trail of the
change in the global financial system
that occurred during this period that is
to say not liberalisation not increasing
trade not globalization in the
technological sense but rather the
changes in the pattern of global
financial governance and macroeconomic
policy which occurred during this period
in particular the 1960s were the last
decade of the successful stabilization
of the world economy under the Bretton
Woods institutions then the 1970s those
institutions were dismantled you had
first a commodities boom and then a debt
boom both of which would drive up the
growth rates of developing countries and
tend to reduce their inequality exactly
as the Kuznets hypothesis would predict
and then the massive turnaround with
return to very high interest rates and
the subsequent debt crises beginning
with Mexico in 1982 quickly spreading
from there to the rest of Latin America
and eventually around the world and with
that you can see an increase in
inequality that is global in scope and
it seems to me that that points very
strongly to problems of global macro
economic governance as being at the
heart of the question something which is
quite different from what the literature
largely has maintained which is that
each country through its choices of
institutions and policies
can control its own destiny as far as
inequality is concerned this evidence
would suggest that if there if that is
true they are doing so in a remarkably
coordinated way it's also true that if
you take mallanna vicious measure of
unweighted between countries inequality
and look at the time pattern of that and
that's the inset one measured with
Africa and the other without it's
essentially the same pattern that is to
say stability some decline in the 1970s
and then steady increase from 1980
onward and that suggests to me that
we're picking up we're both picking up
essentially different aspects of the
same phenomenon a rise in if you like
the inequality of a worldwide
distribution which is to say that
boundaries are simply a way of observing
things and anything that's happening
within countries should also be
happening between them and that is what
we appear to be observing with this
information okay let me turn now I'll
skip over that let me turn now to the
final piece of analysis and I'll take
another five or ten minutes and then be
ready to have questions it's obvious
that there is something quite
unsatisfactory about comparing a measure
that is very narrowly focused on the
between industries component of
manufacturing pay with a measure of
income inequality broadly spoken and
broadly conceived and of course
development economists tend to be
concerned with the broadest measure of
income inequality because that's more
closely associated with economic welfare
so the question then comes up what is
the relationship between the two
measures and that's the basis of the
paper that we're about to publish in
which we did some estimating of the
relationship between our tile measures
and the Gini coefficients in the diner
and squared data set and having said all
the things I've said in a disparaging
tone about diner
Squire I have to take some of them back
because it turns out with some very
simple regressions we can explain almost
sixty percent of the variation in Dinah
jure and Squire in a match sample of
almost 500 observations so what we do
here is we take our measure of
employment / total population and we
also looked at urbanization and
population growth as possible and we
also then add in dummy variables to
account for the various different types
of data in the diner trans choir data
set which turn out to be a very
significant but what we find is that our
measure is very consistently and stable
in different specifications related to
the diner and square measure so it's not
bad as an instrument and with that
realization and with the realization
that inequality tends to be inversely
related to the share of manufacturing
and that you can estimate with
considerable precision the effect of the
different types of data in danger and
Squire on the inequality measure it
seemed to us reasonable to use our
larger data set as instruments to fill
in the gaps and to produce a data set
which is an estimated data set of
household income inequality using the
using the coefficients basically as and
we settled on this model as the one
which is stay blessed with a two
variable model with just the are in
equality measure the share of
manufacturing plus the dummy variables
for the various data types and when you
do that and then project out for example
over the OECD countries to give you a
comparison that I with the graph I
showed earlier you find that in our data
set well gee it's true Sweden
finland that norway are in the low range
for Europe the Mediterranean countries
Spain Greece Portugal or in the high
range the USA is roughly where it is in
the Luxembourg income studies that is to
say some place in the same vicinity as
Italy in Spain France and Australian
some other places in the middle if you
look at how our data match up to dine
insurance but to diners and Squire
across the world it turns out we're
quite close to them in some areas but we
generally think that their measures for
sub-saharan Africa and for Latin America
Middle East are on the high side whereas
for South Asia and for Eastern Europe we
think their measures are slightly on the
low side I could go in I think I'll skip
over the the major detailed listing of
the outliers but we're particularly
skeptical about the measures for
sub-saharan Africa including South
Africa where we think that there if it
is true that inequality is 10 to 20
points higher in Jeanne points than our
our model would predict some reason for
that would have to be forthcoming so far
we haven't seen one but we're
particularly nervous about their
measures because it turns out in fact
that for 16 sub-saharan African
countries they only have a total of 19
observations so you're operating with
basically one survey / country and it's
very hard to say how reliable they were
if you look at the trends in the diner
and Squire data or you can see that
basically they do not find any strong
trend in global inequality I've divided
it up into all we see
countries but and the movement in the
data is an artifact in part of the
extreme variation in sample selection
from one year to the next that variation
persists if you look at our data and in
the match sample to dine adjourn Squire
because of course again we're basically
imposing the sample selection problem on
to our data set but if you look at our
data set as a whole you get a very clear
picture of the pattern across the world
in which the inequality is rising in the
OECD countries from the late 1970s
onward and strongly in the non-oecd
countries from at least the middle to
the end of the 1980s as a pattern
breaking out according to income level
to skip over that i will show you one
more and that is income inequality as we
see it in North America and as they see
it this is the diner John Squire
measures for the US Canada and Mexico
showing Mexico with an extraordinary
lehigh 20-point inequality gap with the
United States but also a decline in the
late 1970s US and Canada pretty close
together if you take our measures we
actually show Mexican inequality to be
only about 10 points higher than in the
u.s. about 10 points less than we would
find for Brazil for example so we think
Mexico is actually an intermediate case
not in the same inequality league as
Brazil and we tend to find that
inequality declined in Mexico until the
advent of the debt crisis that increased
sharply through the debt crisis peaking
in the unfortunate mr. president the
first year of your administration when
the effect of the first week
the first week the first week of your
administration as a direct result of the
collapse of the peso and we find a very
consistent pattern actually for a lot of
developing countries that a currency
crisis and a depreciation drives a wedge
between the incomes of those who sell to
an export market and those who sell to
the internal market and that's going to
have a significant effect on our data
and then as you say exactly in the
subsequent period there is a measurable
improvement which I can only say if you
look at the pattern of the United States
you are certainly swimming against the
tide so with that I will conclude and
thank you and ask four questions I'll
just say one other thing you can get a
lot more information from our website if
you don't want to write down the address
all you have to do is to type in
equality into Google you will get
references to about last time i did it
3.2 million websites and we were listed
number four which was particularly good
considering that we were one or two
places ahead of jean-jacques rousseau
well I do to extend these hypotheses of
too far too fast well is not praying
this but it really is global imbalances
sure if you look I think at the pattern
of trade in the post-war period it is
rising relatively rapidly throughout the
period and i believe it is rising more
rapidly than income in the first 25
years after the Second World War but
it's not producing the systematic
pattern of rising inequality in our data
whereas after nineteen eighty it is oh
and that suggests to me that the effects
of trade are per se ambiguous whereas
the effects of macroeconomic instability
are fairly consistent and since you have
a global pattern a global shift of for
example the real interest rate from a
negative value and throughout most of
the 1970s to with strongly positive
value from early 1980s onward it's one
of my father's laws Galbraith second or
third law is that those who have money
to lend tend to have more money than
those who do not have money to land and
an implication of that is that those who
have money to lend tend to be better off
when interest rates are high and that
would would tend to play into this story
but beyond that it's clear that with the
macro economic crisis a great many
countries came to the end of an
port substituting industrialization
pattern and dismantled protection and as
a result drove down there the relative
incomes of their middle classes so you
had a crisis for industrial classes
that's going to have an increasing in
effective increasing inequality but to
some extent it's offset and I would
suspect it was offset in the Mexican
case by the rising industrialization of
the export sector so that if you have
those two things going on at the same
time the effect of trade per say on
inequality in a developing country is
going to be it seems to me at best
ambiguous is there a systematic
difference I hadn't thought about it
okay the point is that when you're
estimating genies from deciles and
quintiles you'll get another systemic
element of difference yeah
there's the tile it's that that's
beautifully decomposable the genies only
approximately so
right and that's true and my I'll give
you a metaphorical justification then
I'll give you a deeper one the
metaphorical justification is I could
come into this room every day at noon
and just look from here out the window
and tell you what the weather is I don't
need to see the whole sky right and if
I'm looking for changes and this has to
do with if you like the fractal
character of a distribution itself
similar at different scales and if I'm
looking at the same piece of it in a
consistent way I my argument is i can
predict something about what's happening
to the whole distribution i may not be
accurate in all cases and i'll give you
a very clear case of in accuracy if i'm
looking at pay distributions in the
United States in the late 1990s I'm
going to miss the enormous increase in
income distribution that occurred
because of capital income true you're
not going to get everything but the
advantage is that you have a great many
more observations that you've measured
accurately and consistently so it's a
trade-off I would also argue though that
it's not as even as it's better even
than that and then and that is that in a
pay distribution let's say in
manufacturing you have high income and
low income workers the high income
workers will tend to be in petroleum and
machinery the low income workers will
tend to be in food and beverages let's
just say those food and beverages
workers and the garment workers will
tend to be relatively close substitutes
for agricultural workers and service
workers
right and if we see our enormous
increase in inequality as a result of a
relative decline in the pay in those low
paid sectors there are two possibilities
one is that there's an even greater
decline in the piece that you haven't
observed out there in agriculture and
services and the other is that there
isn't if there isn't then the
differential has to be narrowing in
which case workers will disappear from
the low-wage industrial workers back
into agriculture and if there is they
won't and in general they don't so my
argument would be that typically of
movement in the pay inequality you can
observe since the economy is not
hermetically sealed these different
sectors are not hermetically sealed off
from each other is a pretty good
instrument for what you can for what you
can't observe further thought on this is
that there are countries for which we
have broader data sets we have four we
have for Russia we have for China we
have for India we have for the art well
not for India we have for Europe we have
for the United States and so we can
compare our measures where we can do it
with the data Oh with it wit for
manufacturing with the data for the
larger industrial larger economic
sectors and now they're broadly speaking
the two measures are consistent so on a
lot of different grounds I would argue
that that are these measures are a
useful instrument not only for pay and
manufacturing but for what's going on in
the broader economy not perfect you're
not going to get everything right
probably the movement larger it's
certainly larger than the movement and
an overall income distribution but the
chances of them going in opposite
directions I mean we have identified
some cases that what they do but the
chances in general of it happening are
or not nil but they're relatively small
so from that standpoint we feel that the
neglect of these measures has been a
a failing and that again Dinah turn
Squire whom I have a lot of respect for
but all they could do was to take the
historical record of past studies and
bring them all together as best they can
and they're going to run into the
problem that the studies are done in
different ways and the resulting
measures are going to have all kinds of
in comparability Xin them and that's
what we've observed yes I think it would
be yeah I think it would be I think your
your two choices are financial
regionalization and n capital control
and here's where I really come down in
the middle between the
anti-globalization were strict trade and
the pro globalize errs who say
everything is fine it seems to me that
those cases which did the best in the
past 20 years China and India are
clearly distinguished by the fact that
they were not engaged in the global
commercial financial market and
therefore were insulated from the shocks
of the 1980s and China managed to parlay
that into a seven to ten percent growth
rate consistently from then to the
present India into about a four percent
growth rate and the stability of that
growth rate has been the major factor it
seems to me in the reduction of poverty
and the general progress of both places
notwithstanding that both of them have
had increases in inequality internally
the the problem of small countries or
countries which were already deeply
integrated than two
of the global financial community is it
something that has to be addressed in a
different way but here it seems to me
that there is a lesson which is only now
being assimilated from Europe and was I
think an unexpected effect of the Euro
European performance through the 1990s
after the maastricht treaty was
deplorable unemployment rose across
Europe by about 4 percentage points and
we've we've done a paper on that but in
the late 1990s and in the early part of
this decade as the Euro took effect you
began to see a boom in Spain in Portugal
in Greece in the peripheral countries of
Europe I don't know anybody with a
possible exception of panjaa topless who
anticipated it and pads argument which
is straight forward which is that the
creation of a currency that cannot
depreciate the eliminated exchange rate
risk and therefore the distinction
between tradable and non tradable goods
so far as Europeans were concerned
making it possible to bank construction
activity and service expansion in
countries where credit would not be
expanded before to nearly the same
extent because of the risk of loss of
exchange rate risk so it eliminated the
bias toward manufacturing which had
afflicted the peripheral countries and
that caused an absorption of up to ten
percent of the labor force in Spain in
the case of Mexico its course very clear
you have that by us all along the border
thats the I've taught in Monterrey and
you know all the the bright kids that
you encounter they want to be in the
manufacturing sector that's where that's
where the secure dollar income is and
that so it seems to me one way or the
other one can move toward progress but
in a situation in which you have
countries which that which develop and
then as the Asian countries were in 1997
as Mexico was in 1995 hit with crippling
exchange rate crises your living
standards that backward on an almost
arbitrary basis and it's hard to imagine
that
I always argued about NAFTA that the
main effect of NAFTA was on the attitude
of the United States toward Mexico and
that it would create and I argued at the
time before the 95 crisis that it was a
good idea because it would create an
environment where the US would react
more favorably and more rapidly in the
next crisis the but the difficulty I
have with accepting the domestic
explanation for all countries is that if
it were true I would expect a more
random pattern instead I see a systemic
global pattern of rising inequality
which is key to the major transition in
the governance of the world economy
around nineteen eighty where there was a
domestic policy change but it was in the
United States it was in the conduct of
monetary policy that had global
ramifications and when you have such a
evident global instrument the interest
rate in world markets set essentially by
the Federal Reserve it seems to be hard
to overlook the pressure
that puts vulnerable countries it into
and you haven't you have any also the
case of the Asian crisis worthy where
it's hard to argue in a consistent way
that there were clear-cut domestic
policy mistakes of the same kind across
all the countries you had a single a
wave of of retreat of capital from the
region in spite of a very great
diversity of policy and basically people
didn't know it didn't care whether Korea
was different from Indonesia they were
they were reacting to the fact that
everybody else was reacting to the to
the flight from Asia generally and so to
my mind a stable a set of stabilizing
institutions which would prevent those
forces from affecting small countries
would enable them to begin again to have
some of the experience that big
developing countries that China for
example has been able to maintain and
that yr China and India is successful in
this case I mean 11 clear reason it
seems to me is that they're so big that
they can maintain their own position
they are not necessarily selling
themselves on the world market in order
to for example become an insurance
capital as Bangkok wanted to become or
Kuala Lumpur wanted to become and felt
that if they if they gave certain
concessions they would get a degree of
inflow that other countries would not
have and that seems to me to be the kind
of problem the competition for the for
the low for the worst kind of investment
dollar that afflicted the the smaller
countries of Asia
well I said to Paul Davidson who as you
know is an opponent of the Tobin tax
because he says it won't work because it
doesn't it hasn't a big enough effect to
it isn't big enough to stop the kind of
gross movement that we're talking about
and I said Paul but I favor it even
though it won't work and the reason is
that to me it represents more symbolic
than anything else it represents a
symbolic willing willingness of the
advanced countries to accept the
legitimacy of control over capital flow
and if the advanced countries except the
Tobin taxed and they have to accept the
Chilean approach to capital flow or the
Chinese approach or almost anything in
between or for example it's very much
harder for them to reject the sakakibara
Asian monetary fund and my view is that
we need to build institutions
essentially at all kinds of levels in
order to stabilize and the Tobin tax law
it should not be a substitute for those
but it could be a way forward to
acceptance for them